>>> HEY, NO PHONE.
YOU'RE GROUNDED, REMEMBER?
>> OH, MY GOD, I DIDN'T EVEN DO
ANYTHING THAT BAD, MOM.
>> REALLY?
TAYLOR, YOU CAME HOME DRUNK.
YOU'RE 17 YEARS OLD.
>> OH, COME ON, LIKE YOU NEVER
DRANK WHEN YOU WERE MY AGE?
>> IN HIGH SCHOOL, NO.
NOT EVEN A SIP.
NEVER.
>> CHUG, CHUG, CHUG!
>> OH!
♪ I GET KNOCKED DOWN
BUT I GET UP AGAIN
YOU ARE NEVER
GONNA KEEP ME DOWN ♪
♪ I GET KNOCKED DOWN --♪
>> ALCOHOL WAS NOT EVEN ON MY
RADAR AT YOUR AGE.
>> YO, IT'S NOT A PARTY UNTIL
BUFFY SANDY PUKES!
>> I'M OKAY!
♪ HE DRINKS A WHISKEY DRINK
HE DRINKS A LAGER DRINK ♪
>> WELL, SORRY I'M NOT JUST LIKE
YOU, MOM.
SORRY I'M NOT PERFECT.
>> I WASN'T PERFECT, TAYLOR.
I MADE MISTAKES.
I DID THINGS I REGRET.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE NOT
VIRGINS ANYMORE.
>> I DID A COUPLE THINGS I
REGRET.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE NOT
VIRGINS ANYMORE.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
>> NAME ONE MISTAKE YOU MADE.
>> OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
FINE, HERE'S ONE.
I FAILED A TEST ONCE.
IT WAS A BIG TEST.
[ SIREN CHIRPS ]
>> I'M SORRY!
[ CRYING ]
>> THE POINT IS, I NEVER DID
ANYTHING SO STUPID IT FOLLOWED
ME THROUGH MY WHOLE LIFE.
♪♪
>> EVERYTHING ALL RIGHT IN HERE?
>> YEAH, GRANDMA, WE'RE FINE.
MOM, YOU WANT TO KEEP TELLING ME
HOW MUCH OF A DUMBASS I AM?
>> WHAT?
>> TAYLOR!
>> CAN YOU BELIEVE THE WAY SHE
SPEAKS TO ME?
I WOULD NEVER HAVE SPOKEN TO
YOUR GRANDMA BY WAY.
>> SUCK MY -- YOU OLD --!
>> YEAH, WE ALWAYS GOT ALONG
PRETTY WELL.
>> SANDY, IF I CATCH YOU SMOKING
CIGARETTES AGAIN, I WILL SHAVE
YOUR --
HEAD!
>> TAYLOR, YOUR MOM TOLD ME IT
GOT A LITTLE WILD AT A PARTY?
NOW, I'M ALL FOR HAVING FUN, BUT
CALL ME OLD-FASHIONED, I THINK
THERE IS A CERTAIN WAY THAT A
YOUNG LADY OUGHT TO BEHAVE.
>> DAVID BOWIE!
I LOVE YOU, DAVID!
TAKE MY PANTIES!
DAVID!
>> OKAY, I'LL SAY IT THEN.
>> YOU TOLD GRANDMA?
>> OF COURSE I DID, HONEY.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT YOU.
>> WHAT ARE WE WORRIED ABOUT?
>> NOTHING, I'M FINE.
I WENT TO ONE PARTY.
MEANWHILE, MOM'S ACTING LIKE SHE
NEVER HAD FUN IN HER LIFE.
>> WELL, WHEN I MET YOUR MA IN
COLLEGE, SHE CERTAINLY KNEW HOW
TO HAVE A GOOD TIME.
>> HEY.
>> BUT SHE ALWAYS KEPT IT IN
CONTROL.
>> HOW MANY PILLS DID YOU TAKE?
>> THREE.
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
>> YOU BLEW MY ROOMMATE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS YOU.
>> IF SHE'S HARD ON YOU, IT'S
ONLY 'CAUSE SHE LOVES YOU SO
MUCH.
>> I KNOW.
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO LOOK OUT
FOR YOU.
COME HERE.
GIVE ME A HUG.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE STILL GROUNDED.
BUT YOU CAN HAVE YOUR PHONE
BACK.
>> TEXT MESSAGE FROM RYAN,
"PARENTS GONE, COME OVER FOR
EGGPLANT EMOJI."
>> NEVER MIND.
NO, I KNOW WHAT THIS MEANS.
>> YEAH.
♪♪